Welcome to the show.
Donald Trump and Joe Biden had their first
debate last night and there was great interest
in it.
We had 64000 people watched live with me on
our streams.
And I want to go through what happened.
And I have really been struggling with how
to summarize such an insane event.
And this analogy came up the last time I was
on with Joe Rogan in general about the Trump
presidency.
And sometimes, you know, our instinct is to
analyze things with the frameworks we're accustomed
to.
And I can't really analyze yesterday's debate
with the frameworks we're accustomed to because
it was completely insane.
It was the analogy I made to Jeroen.
If he's doing UFC commentary and one of the
fighters sets the other fighter on fire and
you say that's an aggressive tactic.
It's like, no, that doesn't even come close
to encompassing the absurdity of what we're
dealing with.
And I even woke up briefly in the middle of
the night to have a sip of water.
And I thought, how how do I explain what happened
last night?
So I'm going to try we'll do it in pieces.
And hopefully by the end, we'll have sort
of an understanding of what the hell went
on last night and maybe more importantly,
its broader meaning in the election and in
the United States.
Now, the top line is I've never seen a debate
this bad.
That can mean a lot of different things.
So I'll clarify.
But I've been watching presidential debates
since 1996 when I was a mere lad of 12.
I've never seen a debate devolve into being
so worthless as what Donald Trump was able
to turn last night.
At last night's debate into.
I asked some people who are older and I've
been watching debates longer.
They don't remember any debate turning into
as much of a circus as what we saw last night.
So I think we can say with with certainty
that last night was the worst debate in the
history of presidential debates since they've
been recorded and broadcast either via audio
or video.
And my guess is, given what we know about
prior debates earlier in American history,
that last night was the worst debate of any
debate we've seen in presidential campaigns.
Now, to get us into the conversation, let's
discuss it in terms of Biden, Trump and the
moderator, Chris Wallace.
Joe Biden did okay.
Now, I'm not going to lie to you and say Biden
just did great and he was dynamic and energetic
and all of this stuff.
There's no question that Joe Biden was stumbling
quite a bit.
It was not his stutter that was the problem.
It was that he seemed to struggle sort of
sequentially laying out his views on some
issues.
But he did okay.
He didn't collapse as many trumpets were hoping.
Biden had four or five good answers.
His closing was arguably his best moment about
voting, which we will get to.
He had two or three zingers, which I mean,
it sucks that that's even something that we
look at.
But if you were hoping for some zingers, he
had a few.
Donald Trump made the debate impossible.
So, Donald, we could argue, like if you use
a chess analogy, Joe Biden had some good moves
and he had some inaccuracies, no blunders.
Donald Trump flipped the board over and threw
the pieces into the trash and he would not
shut up.
He interrupted what must have been 50 times
during Joe Biden's time to speak.
Trump would just talk over him and insult
him.
Trump went after Joe Biden's son for having
a drug problem.
Trump said Joe Biden wasn't smart.
He made fun of him for the college that he
went to.
Trump did not substantively discuss a single
issue.
And then there was the moderator, Chris Wallace.
Now there are people saying Chris Wallace
did well, given the circumstances.
There are others saying Chris Wallace did
poorly.
What we can't deny is that Chris Wallace did
not have control over the debate.
Chris Wallace was begging and pleading with
Donald Trump to stop interrupting Joe Biden.
Trump wouldn't listen.
Chris Wallace had no ability to cut the mike
of the candidates.
In order for him to have that, both candidates
would have to agree to it.
I can't imagine Trump would ever agree to
that.
So Chris Wallace, as well-intentioned as he
might have been, was helpless to stop Donald
Trump.
So what I can say is that Wallace wasn't equipped
to take control of the debate.
You can say, well, he wasn't given the equipment
because the candidates decided there was no
mute button, that Wallace would have access
to whatever he did as well as he could, you
can say.
But he didn't take control of it.
Trump controlled it.
Now, in terms of the level of discourse that
Trump forced upon us, it couldn't have been
lower or more base or more embarrassing, complete
inability to discuss any policy in detail.
Facts and dignity did not matter.
Trump refused to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups.
And actually, this is the first clip we'll
look at.
Trump activated the militia groups by very
coyly saying they should stand by.
Stand by.
Take a look at this clip.
But are you willing tonight to condemn white
supremacy?
And militia groups.
And to say that they need to stand down and
not add to the violence and a number of these
studies, as we saw in Kenosha.
And as we've seen in Portland.
Sure.
Ethically.
But it has a I would say almost everything
I see is from the left wing, not from the
right.
What do you what do you what are you saying?
I'm willing to do anything.
I want to see what he can do it, sir.
I do it.
Say.
Do you want to call them?
What do you want to call them?
Give me a name.
Give me what?
You surprised us.
Would you like me to can dial out.
That's right.
Stand back and stand by.
But I'll tell you what.
I'll tell you what.
Now, this, of course, stand by is something
very, very different than stand down and all
sorts of white nationalist and militia types
immediately tweeting that that was a call
from Trump for them to be ready to stand by
for the post-election period, a completely
ruinous moment for the discourse and for the
status of the United States of America.
From the debate.
So now, Trump, this is just one of a dozen
examples, two dozen examples.
Trump just talking over Biden not allowing
Biden his time like a petulant child.
B, in that option, no.
Will you acknowledge it with Bernie Sanders
either?
Left on the manifesto will manifest your socialized
medicine.
Look.
Hey, are you there with us?
The fact of the matter is, I beat Bernie Sanders.
Not by much I buy, but beat him a whole hell
of a lot.
I'm not sure I'm here standing.
Facing new charges would have left.
Two days earlier, you would have lost every
brawl.
He knows how to win this Tuesday.
You've got to look very large a deal.
Now, you might think, David, that sounded
like two clips.
That sounded like a clip of Joe Biden talking
and a click a clip of Donald Trump talk talking
superimposed.
No, no.
That's how the debate went throughout.
Donald Trump.
I could play 12 clips like that for you.
I could play 24 clips like that for you.
I won't do it.
May be the lowest moment of the debate.
Was Donald Trump going after Joe Biden's son
for having a drug problem?
They're going to talk about my son, Beau Biden.
You're tired.
I don't know.
I don't know, Beau.
I know who Ron Hunter got thrown out of the
military.
He was thrown out, dishonorably discharged.
That's not true, was it, to cocaine use.
And he didn't have a job until you became
vice president, would you not, as vice president?
He made a fortune in Ukraine, in China, in
at simply areas of the players.
Can you imagine going after it's not even
Biden, but going after Biden because Biden's
son had a drug problem?
This is a health issue when Trump brings up
Joe Biden's son's drug problem.
It's like making fun of someone because your
kid has diabetes.
It's like ridiculing someone because your
kid has cancer.
That's what we're talking about here.
Disgusting.
I mean, just a complete debasement of what
at some point in American history were substantive
policy discussions.
Some good Biden moments here.
While Trump is repeating this idea that Biden
will end the suburbs, this ridiculous idea.
Biden says Trump wouldn't know a suburb unless
he took a wrong turn into one the left supporters.
And once he does that, it's over with.
But if he ever got to run this country and
they ran it the way he would want to run it,
we would have.
We were so nervous.
When I'm gone, by the way, our suburbs would
be gone and you would see problems like you
didn't or a suburb unless you took a wrong
turn.
I know somebody would know, my God, when Biden
did land zingers.
Trump really wasn't able to reply, which was
interesting.
Often Biden would just say, no, you know,
you I'm sorry.
Trump would say no, you know you and did not.
The point is, when Biden was able to put together
a quick retort, Trump actually didn't do so
well.
Biden at one point calling Trump a clown,
that you've already fired most of them because
they didn't do their job.
Some people don't.
Well, here's it with you guys.
Wait a minute.
You got the final word.
Well, it's hard to get any word in with this
clown.
Excuse me, this.
Let me just say it.
No, no, no.
So, as you can see, it's a very low level
of conversation.
They're hilariously there were some Trump
lists who focused on that moment to claim
that it was Biden who was being indecorous
during the debate because he used the word
clown about Donald Trump.
You're sort of missing the forest for the
trees, if that's your takeaway.
And then one more moment, Joe Biden saying
that Donald Trump is the worst president that
the country has ever had.
When Donald Trump tried to interrupt Joe Biden,
Beck's code, that made him put him in a position
that he pays less tax and a schoolteacher
make the money a school teacher makes is because
of him take.
He says he's smart because he can take advantage
of the tax code and he does take advantage
of tax law.
That's why I'm going to eliminate the Trump
tax cuts and we're going to eliminate those
taxes and make sure that we invest in the
people who, in fact, need to help people out
there need help.
But why do you guys do it over the last 25
years?
Because I want you to do it because you aren't
president screwing things up.
You are a senator and the worst president
America has ever had.
Hey, John, let me just say, Joe.
I've done more in in 47 months.
I've done more than you've done in 47.
Here's Joe now, one of the things Biden did
do well, and I thought that this was a good
approach and Biden actually did this really
well, if you go back and watch the 2012 debate
Biden did with Paul Ryan, something Joe Biden
did really well was to laugh off some of the
dumb things that Trump said.
Authoritarians like Trump, narcissists like
Trump.
They want people to be mad.
People like Trump want to cause anger because
it's beneficial to them and they think they
can take advantage of it.
And when Biden would just laugh.
Trump didn't like it.
Take a look at one example.
People want their schools open.
They don't want to be shut down.
They don't want this state shut down.
They want their restaurants.
I look at New York.
It's so sad what's happening in New York.
It's almost like a ghost town.
And I'm not sure it can ever recover what
they've done in New York.
People want their places open.
They want to get back to their label.
They'll be safe.
But they want their schools.
I'm the one that brought back football.
By the way, I brought back bacon football.
It was me.
And I'm very happy to do it.
Trump never once reacted well when Joe Biden
laughed.
And that to the extent that it was a strategy,
I think it's just Biden's instinct to the
extent it was a strategy.
I think it was good.
Now.
Almost ten, ten minutes in now, a bit more
substantively.
Here is Joe Biden pointing out why would you
trust Trump on coronavirus? Trump did his
routine about how great everything was on
coronavirus.
Biden points out Trump's been wrong about
everything.
And he actually raises the topic of injecting
bleach.
And Trump has no way to respond either to
say it was a joke, which we know it was not
before November 1st.
It could also be what is generally available.
Well, we're going to deliver it right away.
We have the military all set up.
Logistically, they're all set up.
We have our military that delivers soldiers
and they can do 200000 a day.
They're going to be this is the same man.
It's all set by Easter.
This should be gone away by the warm weather
had begun.
Maracas like a miracle.
And by the way, maybe could inject some bleach
in your arm and that would take care of it.
This is a sweet said sarcastic.
I was you know that I would have said, sir.
So here's the deal.
Any of you who remember that incident?
No, it was not sarcasm.
Trump has demonstrated no ability to be capable
of sarcasm.
Trump can do nothing.
That was a good moment for Joe Biden.
Check out this comparison now between how
Trump answered.
Will you pledge to accept the election results?
Will you?
Prep pledged to ask your supporters for calm
in the aftermath of the election?
And will you accept the results when they
are certified?
This was the last sort of main topic in the
debate.
And we're going to go to Trump's answer than
Biden's answer.
Trump, when asked, doesn't say yes.
Attacks Maylin voting and says this is ominously
not going to end well.
What's going on?
Take a look at West Virginia mailman selling
the ballots.
They're being sold.
They're being dumped in rivers.
This is a horrible thing for our country.
Is this is not is.
No.
This is not going to end well.
OK, here is Trump again, wildly bringing in
Hillary Clinton of trying to cool Donald Trump,
saying they have Obama and Biden's crimes
on tape, which is out of this world zany.
And if you are watching, you will notice that
Joe Biden seems visibly perplexed by what
Donald Trump is talking about here minutes.
So when I listen to Joe talking about a transition,
there's been no transition from when I won.
I won that election.
And if you look at crooked Hillary Clinton,
if you look at all of the different people.
There was no transition because they came
after me trying to do a coup.
They came after me spying on my campaign.
They started from the day I won.
And even before I won, from the day I came
down the escalator with a first lady, they
were a disaster.
They were a disgrace to our country.
And we've caught them.
We've caught them all.
We've got it all on tape.
And by the way, you gave the idea for the
Logan Act against General Flynn.
You'd better take a look at that, because
we caught you, in a sense.
And President Obama was sitting in the office.
He knew about it, too.
So don't tell me about a free transition as
far as the ballots are concerned.
It's a disaster, a solicited ballot.
OK.
Solicit it is.
Okay.
You're soliciting your asking.
They send it back.
You send it back.
I did that.
If you have an unsolicited they're sending
millions of ballots.
Notice Trump saying everything other than
I'll accept the results once they are certified.
Talking about Hillary.
When asked if he will accept the results.
This is an outrageous authoritarian.
This is not about populism or economic anxiety.
This is authoritarianism.
And then just a little more from Trump, once
again, just horrible.
Trump telling his supporters, go to the polls
and watch.
Now, if you're not a poll worker, you can't
just do this.
You need to register as a poll worker if you
want to be at the polls.
And Trump, again, just trying to cause chaos.
It.
So I first for you, sir.
Finally for the for the vice president.
I hope neither of you will interrupt the other.
Will you urge your supporters to stay calm
during this extended period not to engage
in any civil unrest?
And will you pledge tonight that you will
not declare victory until the election has
been independently certified?
President Trump, I'm about watching my supporters
to go into the polls and watch very carefully,
because that's what has to happen.
I am urging them to do it.
As you know, today, there was a big problem
in Philadelphia.
They went in to watch.
They were called poll watchers, a very safe,
very nice thing.
They were thrown out.
They weren't allowed to watch.
Yeah.
Trump complaining.
You can't just show up and observe.
Yeah, well, that's called voter intimidation.
It's illegal in most states.
I think hopefully all whether it's enforced
is another question.
You can't just show up now for contrast.
Same question to Joe Biden.
And Joe Biden is able to give a one word answer.
And it's the only answer.
And the answer is yes, I will accept the results
when they are certified.
And then Trump still can't contain himself
and interrupts.
And Biden accurately points out Trump has
no idea.
We all are.
You urge your supporters to stay calm while
the vote is counted.
And will you pledge not to?
Claire, victory.
Until the election is independently certified.
Yes.
Here's the deal.
We count the ballots.
As you pointed out, some of these ballots
in some states can't even be opened until
Election Day.
And if there's thousands of ballots going
to take time to do it.
And by the way, our military, they've been
voting by ballots for since the end of the
civil war.
And in effect, and that's and that's what's
happened.
Going to happen.
Why was it not?
Why is it for them somehow not fraudulent?
It's the same process.
It's honest.
No one has established at all that there is
fraud related to mail in ballots, that somehow
it's a fraudulent process already administered.
Let's take a look at my own eyes now.
Know you had an operative looking on.
Go ahead.
They have no idea why.
President Martin.
Go ahead.
He has no idea what he's talking about.
Here's the deal.
The fact is, I will accept it.
And he will to.
You know why?
Because once the winner is declared, after
all the all the ballots are counted, all the
votes are counted.
That will be the end of it.
That would be the end of it.
And if it's me, in fact, fine.
If it's not me, I'll support the outcome and
I'll be a president, not just for the Democrats.
I'll be a president for Democrats and Republicans.
And this guy I want to snack on valid gentlemen.
When you say that's the end of this is the
end of this debate is ballot count.
We're going to leave it to you.
To be continued as in more debates.
So Trump continuing to talk over everyone
as the debate actually ends.
Trump still talking.
This is what a this is what an authoritarian
lunatic sounds like.
Now, could Biden have done better?
Yes, Biden could have done better.
There were missed opportunities for Biden
to point out incredible hypocrisy from Donald
Trump, for example, when Trump's taxes came
up.
Donald Trump said both that the story about
his taxes, his fake news, and actually he
paid millions in taxes.
And Trump said, I'm smart and I take advantage
of the tax law.
Biden could have said he's talking out of
both sides of his mouth.
He's not being honest.
Is the story fake or is it accurate?
But you're happy about it because you're smart
enough not to pay taxes.
Which is it?
It can't be both missed opportunity.
Another instance of this happening was Trump
mentioning that his supporters were allowed
to be poll workers, a poll watchers in Philadelphia
that was towards the end of the debate.
Biden missed the opportunity to say, you can't
just show up.
You can't.
That's not how it works.
It's voter intimidation meant to suppress
the vote.
But this was the whole point.
Trump made the debate impossible.
Now, in the end, when we say Biden did okay
but sort of stumbled and Trump was a raving
lunatic.
What's the impact?
I don't believe Trump's strategy of causing
chaos in the debate served him well.
Trump was so erratic and furious and unhinged
that the contrast with Joe Biden's stability
could not have been more clear.
Now you can say, well, but Joe Biden sounded
confused in some moments after reviewing clips
of the debate.
Now with you and preparing for the show earlier
today, my big picture takeaway is that while
Donald Trump succeeded at preventing substantive
discussion because he's unable to discuss
policy substantively, he made the event a
laughing stock.
Biden comes away looking stable in comparison,
and it's probably bad for Trump.
Trump's outlandish behavior also, by the way,
allowed Biden to take some shots at Trump
without them seeming uncalled for because
compared to what Trump did, it was small potatoes
and that there are people who want that.
There are people who want zingers.
And Biden had a few.
So the big picture right now is the polls
have Biden up six on average.
There is no clear winner here.
And Donald Trump really debased himself.
So I think it's bad for Trump.
Trump needs to make up six points.
Biden did more than well enough not to lose
a six point lead.
Then the question becomes, are people's votes
counted?
But we have to come to some realizations based
on last night.
Number one, if you still like Trump as of
last night, you're probably an authoritarian.
That's something you have to think about.
You know, these claims of well, Trump is a
populist, has his message, is a message of
populism to appeal to economic anxiety.
There was none of that last night.
There was nothing populist about Trump's messages
last night.
This was authoritarianism, plain and simple.
And if you still follow him, you're either
an authoritarian yourself or you're indifferent
to authoritarianism, either to own the libs
or for some other reason.
But again, my overall take is and I so I know
some people disagree with me.
I don't think Biden looked great.
I think it was okay.
But Trump looked so chaotic that Biden looks
good in comparison.
He held his own.
He landed a few shots.
My guess is that the debate was so debased
that the ratings for the second and third
ones will be low.
I had you know, we were joking about mercy
bands during my stream, I said, if if you
if you want to be banned as mercy, to not
be able to watch my streams of the future
debates, let us know.
I think that Trump making it unwatchable will
turn some people away from the future debates.
But I don't think it helps helps Trump big
picture.
What else is important to say?
What else did Biden do?
Well.
I mean, Biden was more substantive.
Biden laid out some proposals in terms of
clean energy, Corona virus economics.
Biden did call out a lot of Trump's B.S.,
including things that Trump denied when there's
video of it happening.
I think that that was good.
Biden correctly linked Trump to the violence
that's happening.
Trump tries to link Biden to violence.
Biden is not the president.
I think Biden did a good job of saying this
is Trump.
This is Trump's America right now.
And then I do think that on the last issue,
which was that a voter fraud, I think it was
a disaster for Trump.
Trump blurted out fraud, fraud, fraud.
Joe Biden very clearly said we're going to
accept the results when they are certified
and there's no evidence of voter fraud.
Vote by mail is the norm in a lot of places.
It's gone absolutely fine.
So you got the sense that in the second half
of the debate, Biden was better equipped to
deal with Trump's constant interruptions and
was able to get some of those good hits in.
Overall, the debate wasn't you know, it was
it was a mess.
It was an s show, as we would say.
And it was that 95 percent because of Donald
Trump and five percent because of Chris Wallace.
We still have to see how it goes.
The polls have tightened and we're going to
talk about that
after
the break.
But
in the meantime, let me know what you made
of the debate.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,